So let's start with
Net Margins this time.
Its the percentage of revenue
retained minus all expenses.
So the correct answer is B here.
You calculate Net Margin as follows.
Take the total Net Profit, divide it by
your total revenue and multiply by 100.
Gross margin is calculated as follows.
Take your gross profit, divide it by
your total revenue, and multiply by 100.
Now both metrics give us an indication
on our quality of performance.
Many companies tell you that we have
a 40% gross margin on our products.
So it can change from sector to sector,
but
you can always measure yourself
against other similar companies.
And see how well or not well
you're doing in relation to them.